POLITICS.
WE SPOKE TO THEM.
YOU CAN HEAR FOR YOURSELF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FIRST QUESTION TO YOU, DENNIS.
I SEE YOU GOT THE TEAM ASSEMBLED
THERE HIEBD -- BEHIND YOU.
GIVEN THE SITUATION IN THE
COUNTRY WHERY ARE RIGHT NOW, WHY
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA?
>> IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA THE ONE
THING THAT WE'RE DOING.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA FOR THE WORLD.
FOR THE WORLD.
AND THIS -- AND PEOPLE ALWAYS
PUT DOWN THE THINGS I DO AND
IT'S WEIRD.
THEY SAY WOW.
HE -- YOU GOT MICHAEL JORDAN,
YOU GOT LEBRON AND STUFF LIKE
THIS.
THEY CAN DO ALL THE COOL THINGS
IN THE WORLD.
BUT ME, WHY NORTH KOREA?
WHY?
I LOVE MY FRIEND.
THIS IS MY FRIEND.
ALL THESE GUYS, I MEAN CLIFF
ROBERTSON, ALL THESE GUYS HERE,
AND THEY ARE THE LAST SOCIAL
VIRUS THAT ACTUALLY SAY HEY,
YES, WE'LL GO.
I'VE HAD A LOT OF GUYS PULL
OUT -- I'VE HAD A LOT OF GUYS
PULL OUT ON ME THAT SAID, HEY --
>> LET ME -- LET ME ADD TO THIS.
PEOPLE HAVE ASKED WHY WE'VE COME
HERE.
WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS -- THESE
GAMES FOR 3 AND A HALF YEARS.
DENNIS -- WE'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW
EACH OTHER OVER THE LAST 3 AND A
HALF YEARS.
OUTSIDE OF WHAT YOU KNOW OF
DENNIS, YOU DON'T KNOW DENNIS.
HE'S GOT A GREAT HEART.
HIS PASSION IS ABOUT CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
WE'RE EXPERIENCED AT THIS.
WE'VE BEEN TO TAIWAN TO THE
VILLAGE WHERE WE'VE MET AND
TALKED TO THE ABORIGINE GROUP
THAT LOST 3,000 PEOPLE DUE TO A
TYPHOON.
WE'VE DONE CAMPS AND CLINICS FOR
REFUGEE CHILDREN, FOR ORPHANAGE,
FOR CHILDREN BEING MISPLACED.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH AROUND THE
WORLD AND WE'RE APOLOGETIC TO
AMERICA BECAUSE, ONE, YOU DON'T
KNOW THIS AND WE HAD NO IDEA THE
TYPE OF NEGATIVE PRESS THAT WE
WERE GOING TO GET FROM THIS
WOULD EXTEND THIS FAR.
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE DO.
WE PLAY BASKETBALL AND THAT'S
WHAT WE LOVE TO DO.
>> CHARLES, I'M WELL AWARE OF
THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
THE MAN SITTING TO YOUR RIGHT,
CLIFF ROBERTSON, BEN BAKER.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, THE
CRITICISM COMES BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOT IN TAIWAN.
YOU ARE IN KOREA.
THAT IS RULED BY A MAN WHO JUST
KILLED HIS UNCLE, KNOWN AS ONE
OF THE BAD ACTORS ON THE GLOBE
AT THIS TIME.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
>> WELL, WE -- WE -- WE DO
UNDERSTAND ONE THING.
I MEAN YOU HAVE TO LIVE UNDER A
ROCK NOT TO KNOW THE PRESS THAT
WAS COMING OR THE PRESS THAT HAS
BEEN OUT THERE PRIOR TO OUR
COMING TO NORTH KOREA.
I THINK THAT IN OUR MINDS, WE
CAME TO DO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
WORLDW
WORLDWIDE, WHICH HAS BEEN THE
SAME SCHEDULE.
THAT HAS BEEN OUR INTENT.
AND AGAIN, WE -- WE ARE
APOLOGETIC.
I HAVE THE SAME REMORSE AND I
THINK THE GUYS HAVE THE SAME
REMORSE THAT IS SIMILAR TO THE
SAME ADDLATION I HAD BEING A
1988 OH LIMP JANUARY.
WE'RE ALL AMERICANS.
WE'RE HERE TO DO GOOD WILL AND
AGAIN, WE DID NOT KNOW THAT IT
WAS GOING TO TAKE THIS TYPE OF
NEGATIVE SPIN ON WHAT WE WERE
DOING BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
APPLICATIONS WE'RE NOT --
POLITICIANS, WE'RE NOT
AMBASSADORS.
>> CHARLTS, I GET IT, BUT IT'S
ABOUT WHERE YOU DO IT AS WELL.
IT'S COMING FROM SOMEBODY THAT
IS A FAN AND A SUPPORTER OF A
LOT OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE.
DENNIS, WHEN YOU CALL THIS RULER
YOUR FRIEND, HE IS NOT A FRIEND
TO THE BAE FAMILY, HE IS NOT A
FRIEND TO YOUR COUNTRY AND YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT, DENNIS.
YOU CAN'T PRETEND THAT YOU DON'T
GET WHY PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT
YOUR FRIEND, KIM JONG-UN.
DO YOU GET WHY THEY'RE UPSET?
>> IT'S AMAZING THAT YOU'RE
SAYING THIS RIGHT NOW.
GIEN GUYS HERE, THEY BELIEVE -
WHAT I'M DOING.
EVERYONE KNOWS EVERYONE HERE.
AND IT'S AMAZING HOW WE STRIVE
ON NEGATIVITY.
THIS GUY, THIS GUY, THIS LEADER,
DO ANYONE NOTICE -- ANYONE KNOW
THAT THIS GUY IS ONLY 31 YEARS
OLD.
>> DENNIS, HE COULD BE 31.
HE COULD BE 51.
HE JUST KILLED HIS UNCLE AND
HE'S HOLDING AN AMERICAN
HOSTAGE.
THE FAMILY IS DESPERATE FOR HIS
RETURN.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY HE'S
BEING HELD.
THIS IS THE GUY YOU CALL YOUR
FRIEND.
>> LISTEN --
>> LISTEN WE'RE PLAYING
SEMANTICS ON THE WORLD "FRIEND."
IT'S AN ENDEARING TERM.
DENNIS MET THE GENTLEMAN.
IT'S NOT SCHEDULED ON OUR EYE
STENOSIS RARE TO DO THAT --
ITINERARY TO DO THAT.
WE'RE HERE TO PLAY A GAME.
YOU'RE TAKING IT OBVIOUSLY TO A
LOT FURTHER STAGE WHEN IS YOU
USE THE TERM "FRIENDS."
>> CHARLES, I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> HE CAME BACK --
>> CHARLT, I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> I AM RIGHT.
IT'S NOT -- IT'S NOT WHETHER --
YOU CAN'T MEET SOMEONE ONCE OR
TWICE AND JUST TAKE THAT --
DARING STEP.
>> THE MAN TO YOUR LEFT,
CHARLES, SAYS HE'S YOUR FRIEND,
SAYS THEY HAVE AFFECTION.
SAYS HE'S A GOOD GUY.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THIS.
>> WATCH THIS.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ONE THING
AROUND THE WORLD.
YOU SAYING -- YOU SAYING TEN
GREAT INDIVIDUALS SITTING RIGHT
IN FRONT OF YOUR FACE AROUND THE
WORLD AND IT'S GOING GLOBAL.
>> UH-HUH.
>> THESE GUYS HAVE SAID CERTAIN
THINGS ABOUT THEIR FAMILIES,
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING ABOUT THEM,
WHY THEY HERE, THEY'RE JUST NOT
ABOUT ME.
IT'S ONE THING, IF I COILED OPEN
THE DOOR -- COULD OPEN THE DOOR
A LITTLE BIT -- JUST A LITTLE
BIT, JUST A LITTLE BIT.
IT AIN'T ABOUT, YOU KNOW, TRYING
TO CRASH -- TRYING TO, YOU KNOW,
CHANGE A WILL.
IT'S ABOUT ONE THING.
NO ONE EVER, EVER ASKED ANYONE
IN THE WORLD WHY WE HAVE
OLYMPICS AND WE HAVE STRUGGLES
AROUND THE WORLD WITH ALL THE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT WHEN THE